to explain to 13 14 year old I
essentially try to give my lecture to my
granddaughter who is much is maybe 14
and then I found out that I have to
change a lot but so there are several
think that's well first of all the idea
which is very simple to any age that if
you have a very very complex system hey
you have to the best is to focus on the
main part n not to like if it is a
picture not to look on all the parts in
the same details so for example in in my
lecture we try to I'm still working on
it but wherever a cut in the forest and
we try to focus on the carton to have
the forest with much less pixel so this
is the general idea of what one call
multi scaling now when it come to
biology you have a complex porting and
you want to understand how it works so
first of all you have to assume that you
could deal with it this is you know not
to listen to people who say that it is
too complex then you say I want to
understand how it works like if you have
a watch and you want to the watch is
already there and you want to understand
how it works you have first to think
about it which I think that certain your
world boy or girl could understand then
then you look on parts of it and try to
figure out how they work when all the
rest is not moving and then you try
after you understand this to let the
rest of it move and then you get a
picture how it works so it's basically
understanding how biological molecule
works and to explain more you have to
take given system like proteins that
chop molecules and you want to
understand white walk
so fast and the main point is that it's
very hard to do it without a computer so
young people understand what is computer
but this is not to send text message but
to actually model how things are working
in when you model it you kind of
understand it it's like simulator for
flight training so you are going inside
the port in and see how it works